today let's talk about energy resources
you've probably already done something
today that used energy resources even
beginning from the moment you woke up
for me the beginning of my day always
starts with making tea
i use energy and every step of this
process my car uses oil when i drive to
the grocery store to get the tea my
stove uses natural gas when i boil the
water and my water heater uses coal
sourced electricity when i wash my mug
in hot water afterwards we use energy
constantly in our daily lives since the
first law of thermodynamics states that
energy cannot be created nor destroyed
where does it all come from
and will we have enough
when we talk about energy resources we
could split it up into two groups
renewable energy and non-renewable
energy
i can always remember what renewable
resources are because the prefix re
means again and the root new refers to
the origin of the energy source so
renewable energy sources are the sources
that we can use again and again and are
quickly restored by natural processes
renewable fuel sources include sunlight
wind moving water biomass from
fast-growing plants and geothermal heat
from the earth
the lifespan of renewable resources
looks like a circle we can use them and
then we can use them again without
worrying about them running out
non-renewable energy sources on the
other hand are sources that exist in a
fixed amount and cannot be easily
replaced these energy sources must be
extracted from the earth and they
include things like nuclear fuel
and fossil fuels which are things like
coal
oil and natural gas
fossil fuels were formed in the geologic
past from the remains of ancient
organisms plants and animals that died
millions of years ago
became buried in the soil partially
decomposed and were exposed to a lot of
heat and pressure
this heat and pressure chemically
rearranged the energy contained within
their bodies into the fossil fuels we
use today
because they take so long to form we
have a finite amount of non-renewable
resources in the earth right now
the lifespan for fossil fuels is a
broken loop a one-way ticket
first the fossil fuel is found
then it has to be extracted
extracting fossil fuels can involve
destructive mining processes that can
pollute surrounding habitats
it then has to be transported to
wherever it will be used
and using fossil fuels means burning
them which releases greenhouse gases and
other pollutants into the atmosphere
also it can take energy to refine and
process some types of fossil fuels so
that they're more helpful to us like
turning crude oil into petroleum gas
diesel and jet fuel and burning the
fossil fuels transforms that energy into
a less organized form of energy like
heat and ash